the president traveled to Hershey
Pennsylvania last night to denounce what
he calls the so-called articles of
impeachment against them the process
continues to move swiftly after House
Democratic leaders formally revealed the
charges of abuse of power and
obstruction of Congress yesterday Nancy
Cordes is on Capitol Hill where the
debate will start tonight Nancy what can
we expect well we can expect arguments
into the night tonight Anthony they will
be ferocious and they will likely
continue into tomorrow if the House
Judiciary Committee does approve these
articles of impeachment sometime
tomorrow they would then be sent to the
full house for a vote by early next week
these too flimsy pathetic ridiculous
articles of impeachment campaigning in
Pennsylvania president Trump questioned
Democrats motives their impeaching me
and there are no crimes this has to be a
first in history there impeaching me you
know why because they want to win an
election and that's the only way they
can do but the new articles of
impeachment warned that the president
will quote remain a threat to national
security and the Constitution if allowed
to remain in office the argument why
don't you just wait amounts to this why
don't you just let him cheat in one more
election the first article of
impeachment abuse of power alleges that
President Trump openly and corruptly
urged Ukraine to publicly announce
investigations into his political
opponent former Vice President Joe Biden
and when the president got caught he
committed his second impe chable Act
obstruction of Congress that article
accuses the president of directing the
unprecedented categorical and
indiscriminate defiance of the house
investigation with the department's of
State Energy and defense
refusing to produce a single document or
record I think this is a clear short
concise argument that the president
abused his power some Democrats like
Congressman Mike Quigley of Illinois
wanted more
serious charges such as bribery are you
satisfied with where the party has ended
up when it comes to these articles of
impeachment I am look this isn't easy
it's complicated layered and textured
you're trying to explain legal matters
to the American people the president has
pushed for a robust defense in the
republican-led Senate but some in his
party don't want to drag the process out
I think the prospect of calling
witnesses in my view seems unlikely
there is a growing consensus among
Senate Republicans that perhaps it might
just be time to move on and if there are
a few or no new witnesses Tony then that
Senate trial could be a lot quicker than
some had initially predicted either way
it's not gonna happen until January
Nancy's speaking of the Senate Senator
McConnell also told reporters that he
would not take up the new trade deal
that House Democrats struck with the
White House until next year why the
delay well it is the end of the year he
says that the Senate calendar is already
full and he also blamed the Democrats
for being so obsessed with impeachment
in his words that there simply isn't
time to deal with this very important
trade pact between the u.s. Mexico and
Canada he wrote on Twitter that quote
Democrats impeachment obsession has
delayed crucial governing
responsibilities while Speaker Pelosi
spokesman said McConnell not taking the
bill up this year is quote total
nonsense
beyond that Tony there are some Senate
Republicans who believe the White House
gave too many concessions to House
Democrats so they're not as eager to
pass this right now as they might have
been all right Nancy thank you very much